[Music]
I've been reading that the brain is like
a muscle it's why getting over a death
is so
hard because your brain has been trained
to feel things for a
person when they go away your head is
still operating under the impression
that it should feel those things for
that person like muscle
memory I think B hold off on the wheel
for
today 12 older to you I feel like I've
aged a lot no yes your husband just died
you're loud my God couldn't really love
you
anymore you've become my
ceiling I wanted to thank you both for
this year I would like to take us to
Paris for the weekend we all deserve
some Joy yes thank you where are we
staying I
beli you were
crazy this is
sexy
you
believe that you
love me you must miss him it's
complicated yeah love is that
way be okay Oliver met someone
else sorry you're having to deal with
that but I'm allowed to feel things too
my husband officially died a year ago
today such a meticulous person he left
behind one hell of a mess do you want to
tell him where you ended up last
night people feel things that are
inconvenient that's
okay
believe you were
crazy can I ask you to have a drink with
me we have been here for you we built
you the nest we sat on you for a year
it's time to
[Music]
hatch We Love
You This Is
Us loving
[Music]
you